[Aplausos]
[Música]
vengo a compartirles algo que espero que
como a mí lo llene mucho de orgullo y
tiene que ver con una historia que
sucedió hace 20 años hace 20 años
nuestro país producía más o menos un
millón y medio de vehículos en ese
tiempo estaba muy joven y me tocó ser
parte de un proyecto que consistía en
evolucionar la industria automotriz de
méxico esto era porque nuestra industria
tenía mucho riesgo porque teníamos muy
pocos proveedores nacionales entonces el
proyecto consistía en cómo nosotros
íbamos a incrementar la proveeduría
nacional el equipo en el que yo estaba
éramos muchos jóvenes y tuvimos que
contratar a expertos internacionales en
esa materia uno de esos expertos estaba
en la ciudad de monterrey nuevo león
un señor bigotón muy echado para
adelante que él fue el que diseñó la
estrategia de cómo íbamos a evolucionar
la industria en méxico cuando ella
concluye manda
y me dice omar esta es la estrategia que
quiero que implementen estás listo y yo
le dije a ver doctor explique me la
explica y le digo sí doctor estoy listo
y vamos a echarle ganas y entonces
voltea de repente se me queda viendo
acuérdense que estaba bigotón y le hace
así que dijiste pelao yo no
sé le dije que le vamos a echar muchas
ganas doctor y me dice hambre ganas le
echan los burros
nosotros tenemos que echarle estrategia
e inteligencia se me quedaron grabadas
esas palabras de aquel doctor yo quiero
decirles que ahora méxico produce casi 5
millones de vehículos y ahora es uno de
los países líderes a nivel mundial en
ese rubro
hay otro rubro global en el cual nuestro
país también es líder de hecho somos el
primer lugar mundial ningún otro país
nos gana somos el país más trabajador
del mundo trabajamos más de 2200 horas
al año y nos retiramos a una edad mayor
de 65 años ninguno nos alcanza número 1
les pido un aplauso por favor para
nosotros los mexicanos
y bueno me pregunto cuando veo otro
ranking realmente merecemos ese aplauso
hay otro ranking que me llama mucho la
atención y es el ranking de calidad de
vida el nivel de calidad de vida a nivel
mundial entonces cuando yo veo los
países que ocupan los primeros lugares
que creen
los países que ocupan los primeros
lugares en calidad de vida son los que
menos trabajo
como una gráfica contraria a nuestro
país que trabaja más de 2200 horas los
que menos horas trabajan son los que
mejor calidad de vida tienen pareciera
que está al revés y hay otra hay otro
ranking que también me llama mucho la
atención y es el ranking de cuánto
tiempo le dedicamos nosotros a nivel
global a las redes sociales por ejemplo
los japoneses en promedio le dedican
aproximadamente 50 minutos al día los
alemanes una hora 20 minutos los
mexicanos en promedio le dedicamos tres
horas y media al día a las redes
sociales nada más a la red
aquí tenemos otras herramientas de
internet teléfono o televisión si
multiplicamos esas tres horas y media en
promedio casi se acumulan 60 días al año
pero si lo convirtamos o lo
convirtiésemos en un horario laboral de
8 horas
estamos hablando de 160 días
se imaginan ustedes que podríamos hacer
con 160 días que proyecto que
emprendimiento que sueño pudiéramos
lograr si tomáramos ese tiempo y lo
aprovechamos o más aún estamos aquí
ubicados ahorita casi 50 personas si
multiplicamos 50 por esos 160 tendríamos
casi 8000 días/hombre disponibles para
hacer un proyecto de impacto social
económico o de beneficio que nos ayude a
mejorar la calidad de vida de nuestra
sociedad
y eso se agrava lo que decía 9 me hace
rato con la pandemia el kobe 19 ha
traído una aceleración de la transición
digital y obviamente de la
hiperconectividad por ejemplo la empresa
de tecnología donde yo trabajo cuando
empezó el kobe en el año 2020 solamente
en los primeros dos meses cuando inició
la pandemia solamente en los primeros
dos meses
ellos pudieron vender lo que tenían
esperado vender en dos años imagina
cuántas veces se acelera la expansión
tecnológica y sigue sucediendo y lo
mismo le pasa a las empresas que están
en el rubro de las comunicaciones
digitales
en dos años los seres humanos estamos
viviendo todo un cambio de cultura y
tenemos que reflexionar cómo nos está
afectando eso nuestro comportamiento
nuestra conducta a nuestro día a día
definitivamente la hiperconectividad
también nos trae retos igual que
oportunidades algunos retos que les
quiero compartir que nos ha tocado ver
es como seres humanos cómo se afecta a
nuestros sentimientos nuestro estado de
ánimo no uno de ellos que vemos mucho es
el tema de la ansiedad si no estamos
conectados que está pasando de que me
estoy perdiendo de que me estoy
desconectando qué noticia no estoy
recibiendo
el tema de la creatividad que es uno que
a mí más me importa
esta hiperconectividad puede ser que
esté disminuyendo nuestra creatividad
porque porque en las redes en estas
herramientas de comunicación digital
pues yo estoy al pendiente de qué está
pasando con todos los demás cuáles son
los problemas de los demás que están
logrando los demás puede ser que me
sirva para inspirar pero cuánto tiempo
le estoy dedicando yo a mis problemas a
mis oportunidades a mis retos cuanto a
creatividad le estoy poniendo a mi
futuro y a lo que yo quiera lograr puede
ser también que no se esté haciendo una
desconexión
social al estar tanto tiempo en las
pantallas cuánto tiempo le dedicamos a
las personas que realmente nos importa o
cuestiones de socialización
aparentemente estamos socializando mucho
pero puede ser que estemos socializando
con conocidos que ni siquiera conocemos
cuánto tiempo le estamos dedicando a
esas personas
la hiperconectividad al final del día es
una tecnología y como cualquier
tecnología ésta puede ser un arma o
puede ser una herramienta hace poco en
juárez estábamos haciendo un proyecto de
tecnología muy interesante yo les decía
una frase al equipo que lo estaba
realizando yo les decía si el tiempo es
oro la tecnología lo puede comprar y esa
fue una frase que agarraron ellos que
les sirvió para hacer su proyecto si a
nosotros nos interesa nuestro tiempo y
sabemos utilizar esta herramienta la
hiperconectividad definitivamente es una
gran ventaja para manejar y para
administrar el recurso más importante
que tenemos los seres humanos que es
el tiempo
es el recurso más valioso que tenemos
los seres humanos como estamos
utilizando nuestro tiempo y la
tecnología de tal manera que ese tiempo
nos traiga beneficios cómo nos estamos
conectando o desconectando de esa
hiperconectividad hace poco ni unas ni
tres palabras que me llamaron mucho la
atención la primera respecto al tiempo a
las redes a las herramientas de
comunicación digital la primera
me duele que me digan que soy antisocial
me gusta que me digan que soy social
pero hablando de las redes sociales y
del tiempo número 2
soy socialmente selectivo
o me conecto a todo
número 3
soy ingeniosamente selectivo
a que me estoy conectando bien que estoy
utilizando mi tiempo
esta es una plática muy rápida pero yo
no quisiera que se nos fuera nomás como
un mensaje y luego mañana ya no me
acuerdo
hablando de ser ingeniosamente
selectivos quisiera hacer una última
reflexión con ustedes y que ojalá que
nos llevemos aunque sea una sola cosa la
pregunta es cómo puedo ser más
ingeniosamente selectivo en la
utilización de mi tiempo respecto a la
tecnología a las redes sociales oa las
herramientas de comunicación digital voy
a hacer unas preguntas ustedes respondan
se las a sí mismos la primera
cómo puedo mejorar mis estrategias si es
que las tengo que ojalá que sí cómo
puedo mejorar mis estrategias en cuanto
al uso de mi tiempo y al uso de la
tecnología
la segunda que es algo que nos mueve
mucho aquí en juárez y que queremos
cambiar
solamente soy usuario y consumidor
de las redes sociales o herramientas de
comunicación digital o soy un creador
estoy utilizando esas herramientas para
crear crear modelos crear soluciones
crear motivación crear liderazgo crear
proyectos
ustedes responden a la 'número tres' en
esta época de hiper conectividad que
tengo tantas herramientas y cada vez voy
a tener más cuáles de ellas debería yo
disminuir su utilización
o inclusive dejar de usarlas hasta
desinstalar las ya está los teléfonos
tienen una función de inteligencia
artificial que si no utilizamos
aplicaciones etcétera solo las van
quitando verdad nosotros deberíamos
hacer algo similar
siguiente pregunta cuáles de esas
herramientas digitales debería utilizar
de una mejor manera seguir las usando
pero de una forma más eficiente o más
productiva y finalmente
también hay herramientas digitales que
no estoy utilizando
porque probablemente ya esté saturado de
muchas herramientas esté congestionado
mi mente de tantas opciones que existen
la última pregunta es
kuala herramientas nuevas debería yo
incorporar a mi vida que me pueda servir
para lograr mis objetivos de mejorar
calidad de vida y de mi sociedad en el
corto y mediano plazo muchas gracias a
todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]